you kind of obviously got introduced in
the game at least from my understanding
when i first started hearing you was
through the migos
what was your initial introduction with
them being a kid from canada being that
at that time
the migos were active out here because i
lived in tampa when the migos started to
pop and them dudes was they was really
they were really out here doing mad
shows had their mcm bags on [ __ ]
shootouts and [ __ ] all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] was popping off but how did this
how did those two worlds connect um so i
just connected with them on twitter like
that i was hitting up everyone on
twitter facebook youtube i was just
handing people up so i just like hit up
one of their boys i was like yo
play play some of the play some of my
beats for them and i'm going to give you
some beats to rap on at the time this
guy wasn't even rapping he was like i'm
actually engineering them so send the
pack i sent the pack and then from there
you know what i'm saying that easy yeah
it's crazy because
nowadays
way harder to do that think about like
dm in someone like no one's gonna check
your dm it's crazy that's why like
people always ask me for advice and
stuff i'm like i don't even know what
kind of advice to give somebody because
what worked for me it's gonna be hard to
work for someone else
back in the day like there wasn't a lot
of people trying to be a producer it
wasn't cool to be in music it was very
like unrealistic so everyone kind of
like stayed away from it so like but
like with the internet and how the
internet was working and stuff i used
that to my advantage because like i was
just a kid from canada i'm from a town
of 30 000 people like what part of
canada are you from like i'm from like
niagara region so it's like by niagara
falls yeah just outside of niagara falls
why you're a buffalo fan you know what
i'm saying there we go so like i was
like i grew up on the border of buffalo
in a small town 30 000 people